challenge l'objectif est de reproduire
ce que fait harry styles sur scène
crashé au dessus de lui à la façon d'une
baleine alors ça il le fait mais ça fait
un beau et bru regarder
si c'est ça
oser
[Musique]
résultat castaldi allez-y faites le dire
attention c'est dur à faire aller si on
finira par isabelle déjà que c'est la
voiture s'arrête
oui c'est de la vodka et de réalisme
elle nous a pas fait la malle maroc ram
mais sans les aléas vous n'en voudra pas
j'imagine chez vous alors je me casse
[Rires]
[Musique]
encore en chantier naval décoller arrêt
n arrive pas bon ménage en toile et se
dit mais qu'est ce qu'elle fait et
d'orge et dégueulasse faire allez on
arrête alors de la couture et la
séquence
bravo tout mouillé le faire vous plombe
annonce qu'elle a clôturé ces bons
restent darty en tout cas elle a voulu
me casser la gueule hissène